we're going to begin with this on this
holiday weekend nearly half of the
country will start Memorial Day weekend
under a severe weather threat triple-a
estimates nearly 43 million people will
travel over the next three days many of
them could see thunderstorms and flash
flooding parts of Missouri's capital
city are still shut down more than 24
hours after a devastating tornado
touched down CBS this morning lead
national correspondent David Begg know
is in Jefferson City David how are folks
doing this morning Anthony they keep
telling us they're OK good morning to
you but they're still stunned look the
mayor says no injuries no deaths here in
the city but this happened on the cover
of darkness right they couldn't even see
this tornado coming but the warning
sirens were blaring and when they
finally got daylight this is what they
saw the majesty of Mother Nature the
back row of this story tornado
Toyota lot flew into the third row in
front of it and all of these cars tossed
like toys now the man who owns the
dealership was showing us he said David
the tornado went right through the third
row went through my service center and
right into the downtown of Missouri's
capital city daylight brought a clearer
picture of the damage left behind after
the violent tornado with winds that
reached an estimated 160 miles per hour
tore through Jefferson City the night
before everything is just shaking so I'm
telling my grandmother I think neither
going to basement our mod Cody said he
had very little time to get his disabled
grandparents to safety before the roof
was ripped off their house I look up and
I'm just like freeze a little bit I was
like a shot kind of look oh I'm like
there's no roof well thank goodness for
this basement though yeah if you didn't
have this basement we didn't had two
basement I don't know what whatever
happened there were no deaths in
Jefferson City all over town there's
power lines down yes that's the mayor
Carey Turgeon who told us people were
warned 30 minutes before the tornado
touched down so there was a siren that
went off to watch Jefferson City yes we
have the outdoor warning sirens and I
heard them in fact I just laid down to
go to bed about 11:15 and heard it Kevin
Riley says he's never seen a storm this
strong hit Jefferson City
his grandfather opened
our business here eighty-three years ago
he estimates the 90% of his vehicles are
damaged I'm stunned I'm kind of in a
numb stage right now what was your
reaction when you first strove up and
took a look almost cried which I could
almost do now and this is mr. Riley's
dealership listen the threat is not over
through Memorial Day there is the threat
of more severe weather here in Missouri
and Tony just about three miles from we
are the Missouri River is actually at
major flood stage the airport has been
closed and there is a chance within the
next 12 to 24 hours the water could
overtop the levees flood the airport and
the business district here in North
Jefferson City Wow David you mentioned
the majesty of nature indeed majesty but
also terror I mean those pictures are
unbelievable yeah you see why I felt
like crying yeah I would've cried yeah